dos días después del anuncio oficial el
primer caso de kobe 19 en corea del
norte kim jong-un ha convocado una
segunda reunión de emergencia las cifras
no son claras y faltan medios de
detención del virus las autoridades
hablan de 500.000 casos de fiebre desde
finales de abril sin precisar el número
exacto de contagios de kobe 19 este
sábado el líder norcoreano calificó la
situación de grave para el país ninguno
de los 25 millones de habitantes está
vacunado contra el coronavirus ya que
desde pyongyang se rechazó las ofertas
de la organización mundial de la salud
de china y de rusia según este experto
correa del norte podría abrirse pronto a
la ayuda internacional
es posible que hayan revelado estos
casos intencionalmente con el fin de
abrir nuevas opciones como reconsiderar
la adquisición de vacunas kóvacs o
recibir la ayuda internacional con el
rango sin gas
si es posible
cora del norte cerró sus fronteras de
enero del 2020 tras del rebrote de casos
por comida en china el país no envió
atletas a los juegos olímpicos de tokio
y pekín algo por lo que siempre se
habían enorgullecido de mantener a raya
la pandemia las autoridades ordenan
ahora una contención drástica de la
población
los norcoreanos están temerosos por el
coi y el ambiente en el país se ha
puesto tenso entonces para elevar la
moral de la población
es probable que corea del norte acelere
nuevas pruebas de misiles
tan cansina
las imágenes de satélite indican que
corea del norte se está preparando para
realizar una prueba nuclear y que podría
tener lugar este mismo mes según los
eeuu